our medical contributor now dr david
agus joins us with ideas to keep you
and your thanksgiving gathering safe dr
agus good morning happy thanksgiving to
you
as we mentioned yesterday
the deadliest day of the pandemic was
yesterday
the deadliest day in more than six
months so the question is
you know there is a lot of second
guessing going on about how to stay safe
what's the best course of action
well obviously 2 100 deaths each of the
last two days
cases going up so we all have to be care
careful if we're getting together with
people and a lot of people are
the following you need to pay attention
to one is each pod that is who you live
with as a pod needs to have separate
tables and be separated have one place
where there's food and go
and have wipes so you can actually have
different utensils or wipe the utensils
so each family is going to eat different
focus the meal
in short periods so you're eating the
meal and then the rest of the time where
you're talking and socializing your
social distance
and wearing a mask is critical we just
saw that national weather map
the good news is most of the country can
have their thanksgiving
outdoors or with the windows open better
ventilation
doing it outdoors will dramatically
reduce the risk of spread of the virus
there's no question that getting
together increases risk the hope is you
could do some of these things
to lessen the risk i know we've seen a
lot of long lines for testing ahead of
the holiday does
does testing ensure safety
well no i mean obviously you asked a
leading question and the answer clearly
is no it is not a free pass
so many people are being tested now
first of all because case numbers are
through the roof and people were been
exposed but also
they want to get there with a grandma or
get together with their family during
the uh the holiday and they got a test
that test is not a free pass to
keep the mask off it's not a free task
to not social distance
testing is great identifying people and
then quarantining them or
contact racing critical but wear a mask
and social distance please even if you
tested negative over the last couple
days
want to switch gears now to some vaccine
news astrazeneca is facing some new
questions about its
vaccine's efficacy after admitting a key
mistake in the dosage given to some
trial participants how significant is
this
well early in the trial i mean it showed
you the complexity of manufacturing it
was calculated the wrong dose in the
vial
so the first several thousand patients
received a half a dose instead of a full
dose
and the second dose of the vaccine they
got a full dose well it turns out in
those individuals
they had a better response than people
who got full dose
and full dose and so there are a lot of
reasons why we think it's because that
the
the the the vector what what is around
the
the spike you make an immune response to
and a lesser dose folks and that enables
you to make a better immune response to
that spike protein
still remarkably important vaccine
remarkably important trial
yeah that's just one vaccine from one
supplier
but we're looking for others dr david
agus thank you